I'D LIKE TO- GIVE
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT TO EIGHT MEMBER
OF THE HUMAN SERVICES FAMILY-
SENATOR HANNAH BETH JACKSON TO
SAY IT'S HER BIRTHDAY AND-
BIRTHDAY AND I HOPE YOU ENJOY
THE BEFORE. ON BECAUSE OF THE
TEAM HERE. COURSE I'D ALSO LIKE
TO WALK WHEN AGAIN ARE CHAIR
SENATOR BRIAN JONES. HELLO
THANK YOU FOR JOINING AND WE
ALSO HAVE OUR NEW MEMBER FOR BE
SERVE COME THAT'S- MELISSA
MULLIN. OUR WAS SWORN IN JUST
YES. SO THE SPEECH BE HER FOR
MEETING IN. AND TODAY'S CA. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK LEADERSHIP
US SENATE PROTO TONY. THE SEC
OF SAN ERICA US THE STAFF AT
THE DATA THE I. T. STAFF THE
ENTIRE IN A TEAM WORKING TO
ENSURE THAT SECOND ITS BUSINESS
PROVIDE A SAFE OP. FOR PUBLIC
PART TO. AND WITH TO THE COMMON
EMERGENCE INTERPRET THE-
SENATOR THE STAFF THE MUSLIM
AND NOT IS A GATHER TO HERE TO
SOCIAL. AND COME WITH THE ORDER
TO SAN WILL BE IN THIS HE- AND
HAS NOISES IT JUST TO NOR
PRACTICE IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE- AND TO HAVE. TO THE
LEDGE PROCESS. WILL CONDUCT
THANK YOU IT BOY THE- HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF PUBLIC AND. FORTY
IN ORDER TO ALLOW. THE TO ACT
TO ACT OUR PURSUE WE HAVE A
MEMBER OF THE- TO HEAR ROOMS.
ARE ONE ROOM TO BE THAT SOCIAL
JUST RICK ALLOW WE WILL BE
USING IT. SERVICE FOR END OF IT.
WHO WISH TO TELL TODAY. FOR ALL
AND- WHICH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC.
THE PARTISAN. TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POST ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEB. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE TV SCREEN.
TODAY PER TO FOR NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE
SIX FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. FIVE NINE ZERO
FOUR THREE FIVE FIVE. FOR THOSE
PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE THE MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THE TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING. THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
NINETEEN THE COURT DURING THE
CURRENT AS IS BECAUSE- AND IN.
AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO ARE JUST.
MAY BE FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. EVERY EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS AND AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LACK TIMES
FOR PARTICIPANTS FOR JUSTIN TO
THE USE OR NEW ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGISTS. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENTS ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD.
TODAY WE HAVE NINE BILLS ON THE
AGENDA. THREE OF WHICH ARE ON
CONSENT THOSE BILLS ARE SB
EIGHT EIGHT TWO BY SENATOR
WIENER. SB ONE TWO FIVE NINE BY
CENTER TACO. AND SB ONE SIX
FOUR FOR TITLE. SELECT REMIND
THEM OF THE KU TO ON YOUR MY IS
INTO. THE MICROPHONE. THIS ONE
FROM OF THE CAN YOU. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATION THE BILL. I'D
LIKE TO STOP WISHING FOR SO
SECRETARY KEEP ARE THE ROLL.
THE MEMBERS PLEASE TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES HER TITLE HERE ARE
HERE. BELL BELL HERE JACKSON
YOUR FAX HERE JONES JONES HERE
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ PAM HERE AND
HERE WINNER. WHERE'S WE A
QUORUM. WE HAVE A QUORUM. SO AT
THIS MOMENT WE WILL GO AND-
YOU'RE IN THE PENALTY BOX. THE
FIVE. SO EARLIER WE ARE WHAT
NOT TO A QUICK SO TO ONE AGAIN
WHY OUR NEW WITH MEMBER OF THE
SENATE SO MELENDEZ WELCOME AND
WALKING THE COMMITTEE COME. AND
AT THIS WALL HERE OR FOR BILL
WE- THANK. THE HAVE OUR AUTHOR
HERE. THE CARD. YEAH SO FIRST
BILL IS SB NINE ZERO SEVEN.
WELCOME SENATOR ARCH. PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO YOUR BILL. I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE WITNESSED
WILL PROVIDE TESTIMONY VIçT
TELL TODAY. AS OUR I'M ASSUMING
THEY'RE HERE YES MA'AM. MY I
BEGIN MY THANK YOU AND WELCOME.
MELISSA MILLER. THE SET AND
IT'S TO HAVE YOU ABOARD. AND TO
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR A
LONG ME TO MAKE MY PRESENT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND OF
COURSE THE MEMBER THANK ONCE
AGAIN. I'M HERE TO REPRESENT
SENATE BILL NINE OH SEVEN WHICH
PERTAINS TO MILITARY CHILD
ADVOCACY. AS CHAIR OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON VETERANS
AFFAIRS I AM EXTREMELY
CONCERNED FOR THE WELFARE OF
ALL THE CHILDREN AT THIRTY
THREE MILITARY BASES AND
INSTALLATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA HAS
RESPONSIBILITY AND AUTHORITY TO
ADDRESS CHILD WELFARE REGARDING
ALL CHILDREN RESIDING IN THE
STATE INCLUDING THE AUTHORITY
TO REMOVE CHILDREN. FROM THEIR
FAMILIES DUE TO MALTREATMENT.
THE DEPARTMENT DEFENSE HAS THE
STATUTORY OBLIGATIONS TO
ADDRESS CHILD ABUSE AND
MILITARY FAMILIES INCLUDING
REPORTING ALL ALLEGATIONS OF
CHILD ABUSE AND NEGLECT TO
LOCAL CHILD PROTECTIVE
AUTHORITIES FOR INVESTIGATION.
MOST OFTEN INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES
CONDUCT THESE INVESTIGATIONS.
HOWEVER THERE IS NO
CORRESPONDING REQUIREMENT FOR
THE COUNTY SHOULD NOTIFY THE
LOCAL MILITARY INSTALLATIONS
WHEN AN INVESTIGATION OF A
MILITARY FAMILY IS BEING
CONDUCTED. AS A RESULT COUNTY
CHILD WELFARE SERVICE OFFICES
MAY NOT CROSS FOR MILITARY
FAMILIES INVOLVED IN CASES OF
ALLEGED CHILD ABUSE TO SERVICE
PROVIDERS ON THE BASE ITSELF
SUCH AS THE FAMILY ADVOCACY
PROGRAM. IN THE WORSTCASE
SCENARIO A MILITARY FAMILY
INVOLVED IN AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION OF AN ALLEGED
CHILD ABUSE OR NEGLECT COULD BE
REASSIGNED TO ANOTHER STATE
WITHOUT THE KNOWLEDGE OF THE
MILITARY PUTTING MILITARY
CHILDREN IN DANGER OF CONTINUED
ABUSE WITHOUT NEEDED
INTERVENTION. AS FAMILIES
CONTINUE TO SHELTER AT HOME THE
NUMBER OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
CASES HAVE BEEN INCREASED
HOWEVER THE NUMBER OF CHILD
ABUSE CASES REPORTED HAVE
DECREASED. WELL SCHOOL IS NOT
IN SESSION AND CHILDREN ARE NOT
ATTENDING DAYCARE OR CAMPS OR
OTHER FACILITIES OUTSIDE THE
HOUSEHOLD IT IS LIKELY THAT
CASES OF CHILD ABUSE ARE GOING
TO BE UNNOTICED OR NOT EVEN
REPORTED. WITHOUT ANOTHER PARTY
INTERACTING AND MINORING KIDS
ON A REGULAR BASIS CHILDREN AND
ABUSIVE OR NEGLECTED HOMES ARE
AT HIGHER RISK. SB NINE OH
SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL CHILD
WELFARE SERVICE OFFICES IN
CASES OF ALLEGED CHILD ABUSE OR
NEGLECT TO DETERMINE IF THE
PARENT OR GUARDIAN. THE
MILITARY MEMBER. SB NINE OH
SEVEN WOULD HAVE HE CHILDREN
OF MEN FAMILIES BY COORDINATION
BETWEEN ON BASE FAMILY ADVOCACY
PROGRAMS AND THE COUNTY CHILD
WELFARE SERVICE OFFICES. THE
BILL WOULD ALSO CLARIFY THAT
CHILD WELFARE SERVICE OFFICES
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO DEVELOP
MEMORANDUMS OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH MILITARY INSTALLATIONS
WITH THEIR JURISDICTIONS. THESE
MO USE FACILITATE BETTER
COMMUNICATION AND COOPERATION
BETWEEN BASES AND A COUNTIES
DURING THE INVESTIGATION OF
CHILD ABUSE. TWENTY FOUR STATES
HAVE ALREADY PASSED SIMILAR
LEGISLATION. SB NINE OH SEVEN
IS A WIN WIN FOR THE STATE
MILITARY SUPPORT PROGRAMS AND
MILITARY FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE CAN
INCREASE ACCESS TO PREVENTION
SERVICES FOR MILITARY FAMILIES
AND FOSTER BETTER COORDINATION
OF SERVICES BETWEEN MILITARY
BASES AND COUNTY SUPPORT
SERVICES ALL TO THE BENEFIT OF
MILITARY CHILDREN AND THEIR
FAMILIES. TODAY I HAVE KATHY
CENTER LANE MCDONALD DEPUTY
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA AND IT KELLY MAY
DOUGLAS SOUTHWEST REGIONAL LAYS
ON FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE STATE LIAISON OFFICE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. IN WITH
THIS. I ASK RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR DUE TO CONSTRAINTS THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY.
AND YOU CLEANING PROTOCOLS A
COMMITTEES WILL INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY
WITNESSES FOR SOME UP FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION WILL
ONLY BE PERMITTED A TOTAL OF
THREE MINUTES ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
MEASURES ONCE AGAIN THE PHONE
NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. THREE THREE SIX FOUR
FOUR FOUR ONE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. FIVE NINE ZERO FOUR
THREE FIVE FIVE. WE WILL NOW
OPEN UP FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THIS BILL. ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WHO WISH. ON
THE PHONE YEAH. ARE COMMON IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE OH SEVEN.
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ON
THE PHONE MODERATOR. THEN ZERO.
IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THE MOUNTAINS
MODERATE MADAM AND. MADAM MADAM
TURN MEMBERS I'M NOT SURE GOING
ON HOW KATHY SO WE MAKE WITH
THE WHILE FOR DIRECTORS
OFFICIALLY I'VE BEEN A NEW AND
THEN NEEDED BUT I JUST GOT A
NEEDED I THINK WE'RE- I'LL JUST
QUICK FOR A MENTAL KELLY TO DO
HER THING. ON PETER BDA IS
PRETTY TO SUPPORT THE FOR JUST.
WE ON A DIFFERENT BURKE OF THE
BILL FIRST YEARS WITH PERCENT
OF THE OF THE DEPARTMENT OF.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF COUNTY
ALREADY HAVE MEMORY OF. WITH
THEIR LOCAL NO IN. BUT A LOT
NOT CLEAR IT'S ALLOW OR CORD SO
THE AREA THE MEMORANDA COVER.
SO WE SEE THIS APPROACH TO THE
GOLD MY THOUGHT OF FANS. GATHER
INFORMATION AS THEY DO THE- THE
INVESTIGATION OFFER SERVICES TO
THE FAMILY ON THE TILE WATER
SIDE AND THEN COURTNEY AS
APPROPRIATE ON THE MILITARY
SIDE AS WELL THE SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED TO FAMILIES ON DECENT
CAN BE EXTREMELY HELPFUL AND
THEY- CAN BE AVAILABLE IN TIMES
WHEN WE FIND. THAT ALLEGATION
MAY NOT BE FOUND IT BUT THERE
COULD BE ISSUES WITH THAT
FAMILY IT DOESN'T RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF ABUSE AND NEGLECT THE
CHILD WOULD NEED TO COME IN OUR
SYSTEM BUT WORKING WITH THE
MILITARY WE IDENTIFY SERVICES
THAT THE- FROM. WHAT WE. THANK
YOU MODERATE CAN WE HAVE OUR
NEXT SPEAKER A KELLY MAY
DOUGLAS SITE. YES CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. THANK YOU CHAIR HURTADO
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME KELLY NAY DOUGLAS I'M NOT
GOING TO HAPPEN DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE AND I NEED TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE OF THEM
IN. CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
SECOND HIGHEST NUMBER OF
CHILDREN OF ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS AT
NEARLY A HUNDRED THOUSAND
APPROXIMATELY 70% OF MILITARY
FAMILIES LIVE OFF BASE WITHIN
THE COMMUNITY. I COMBINED WITH
FREQUENT CREEK UNTIL FOR
INCIDENTAL A CHILD ABUSE AND
NEGLECT WITHIN MILITARY FAMILY
REMAIN UNKNOWN. I'M REPORTED
THE STATE. SENATOR OFFICE
STATED THAT THEY DOD IS YOU
PROVIDING FAMILY ADVOCATE
AVERAGE PROGRAM AT EACH
MILITARY ELATION PREVENTION
RESPOND HOW TO BE A AND NEGLECT
PAID THE NOT FAMILY. FEDERAL
LAW REQUIRES ALL THE OF THE
PARKING ALL COURT. CASES AND
HOW THE INTERNET THE LOOK
COUNTY HOW WELL SIR DR. THE LOG
SO WHERE THAT THE DATE
RECIPROCITY WITH COUNTY AFTER
MILITARY FAMILIES INVOLVED IN
THE ALLEGED COUNTY THAT WHEN IT.
YOUR SO CAN DOWN THE JAM
GREATLY FROM HEAVEN AND- EIGHT
AMPS PROVIDED BY THE FAMILY OF
THE PROBE DURING. STAGES OF ON
GOING IN. IDEALLY THE
PARTNERSHIP THE A MALE BASE
KELLY EVERYTHING PROGRAM AND A
COUNTY CHILD SO. OFFICE
TOMORROW LIGHT IN A YOU THERE.
BUT FOUND THAT OCCASIONALLY
COUNTY NOT BELIEVE THAT THEY
THE DEL AUTHORITY TO ENTER INTO
THE FAMILIAR DESPITE A HISTORY
OF COUNTY LIKE ONLY A GIRL. I'M
HAVING. COULD THERE LOCAL KATE
THAT. WE BELIEVE THAT TO THE
BILL EIGHT POLICY. ACCOUNTING
HELLO SERVICES OFFICE ARE
OPERATING TO DEVELOP AN
MILLION. WILL HAVE MANY BET
BENEFIT MAINLY HELPING TO
INCREASE AND IMPROVE
COMMUNICATION AND COLLABORATION
ON OPEN CASES. ARE INCREASING
MILITARY MIGHT ACT THAT TO THE
COURT. ON AND OFF BASE. AND
ALLOW FOR BETTER CORD-
AVAILABLE IN. WE AND I.
COMMUNITY OMELET THAT I. LIKE
TO THE TRADE YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY YOUR VOTE AND I'M
HAPPY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY I THIS POINT WE WILL
OPEN UP FOR CALM ON THIS BILL.
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND I'M HERE IN THIS
ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO THREE WHO
WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMON
IN SUPPORT OF SB. NINE ZERO
SEVEN. THREE NINE OKAY. I THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD TRUMP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE ZERO
SEVEN WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU
ARE NINE ONE ONE TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS CARROT SMITE WITH
THE NAVY- ON BEHALF OF THE
MILITARY SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. MODERATOR DO WE-
KNOW WHAT CAN WE ASK ALL
INDIVIDUALS WE NEED TO TEST FOR
THE POOR TO PRESS ONE ZERO. Q.
THE NEXT RETURN TO LINE OF ONE
ZERO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MODERATE CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. AND LINE ONE ZERO
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
GIVE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE ONE NOW IT'S
FROM THE LINE OF ONE ONE THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
SORRY I WASN'T SURE IF YOU CAN
HEAR ME BEFORE THIS IS ONLY BE
SANTOS ON BEHALF OF AT THE
IDEAL CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE. THANK YOU. THINK
MURDER IF YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINE AND- CALL THE
SUPPORT WITH THIS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE. ARE ONCE AGAIN
PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL. FAMILY TURNED TO LINE OF
ONE ONE TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GUESTS MIGHT FOR THE
NAVY ON BEHALF OF THE MILITARY
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. WE
HAVE NO OTHER LINES IN Q. OKAY.
THANK YOU AT THIS MOMENT- WE
WILL. MOVE AHEAD DO WE HAVE
MODERATED Q. PLEASE CHECK THE
LINE ONCE AGAIN. FOR OPPOSITION
OF SB NINE ZERO SEVEN. THANK
YOU FOR SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE TEN ZERO FOR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. MMHM
MMHM MODERATOR CAN WE PLEASE
CHECK THE LINES FOR POSITIONS
TO SB NINE ZERO SEVEN. AND WE
HAVE- LINES IN Q. DO WE HAVE
ANY OPPOSITION TO SB NINE ZERO
SEVEN AND ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE. THREE NINE. DO WE HAVE
ANY OF OUR MEMBERS THAT HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AT THIS
MOMENT. IF YOU'RE LIKE. JERRY
ALL DIRECTIONS. AB AIRPORT
RECORD AND COAST GUARD IN OUR
NEW SPACE FORCED. TO ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGE MEMORIAL DAY COMING
UP AT THE END OF THE MONTH. AND
LIKE TO THANK COMMITTEE IN THE
CHAIR BECAUSE THIS BILL SB
SEVEN OBVIOUSLY NOT. WHICH THE
FAMILIES OF THESE MEN AND WOMEN
GREAT NATION AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY IT BRINGS
RECOGNITION AND PROTECTION
SERVICES TO THE FAMILY ENERGY I
MET IN THIRTY THREE MILITARY
BASES ACROSS THE STATE. FORTY
OF THE BONTA PFAM WE PROTECT
THOSE. IN THIS. GOES IN THE
DIRECTION AND FOR THAT EXPECT
TO ASK FOR I'VE- THANK YOU
SENATOR ARCHULETA WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR PENN US
SECRETARY. CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BUT FIRST I'D LIKE TO
REMIND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
TURN ON THE MICROPHONE AND
SPEAK INTO IT SO THAT MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CAN HEAR THEM. SB
NINE OH SEVEN ARCHED. THE
MOTION IS THE PAST TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS HER TITLE. I
DON'T BY THE BELL. BELL BY
JACKSON ALL RIGHT JACKSON I AM
JONES I JONES BY MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE PAN. AN AYE WIENER
WIENER AYE SEVEN ZERO VOTE. SO
THAT BILL IS OUT WITH THE SEVEN
ZERO VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
EXCELLENT ADVENTURE THANK YOU
COMMITTEE OKAY UP NEXT WE HAVE
OUR- SB NINE ONE TWO. WELCOME
SENATOR BELL. YES MA'AM TARA
O'TOOLE- ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
FOR MY SIS THAT'S- THAT IS FINE
YES- WELL GOOD AFTERNOON- CHURN
MEMBERS TODAY IMPRISONING SB
NINE ONE TWO THIS IS A BILL
THAT WOULD RESPOND TO THE NEEDS
OF FOSTER. OUR YOUTH AN AWFUL
STATUS KERN SIX PROTOCOLS FOR
FOSTER YOU'VE DURING THEM THE
OF THE FUTURE SEE. OF THE NIGHT
NINETEEN HAS CREATED ON
PRESIDENT PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS
AND PUT CALIFORNIA IN A STATE
OF EMERGENCY. AS WE WANT TO THE
MID AND MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF
THE CRISIS WILL NOT FORGET
PEOPLE WILL SUFFER MOST FROM
THE INSTABILITY AND
UNCERTAINTY. NOW MORE THAN EVER
FOSTER YOUTH NEED OUR SUPPORT.
WHAT WHEN A CRISIS HAPPENS
FOSTER YOU USUALLY HIT HARDEST
AND RIGHT NOW FOSTER YOU FOR
FACING ISOLATION. DO NOT FORGET
LEARNING OR OR HOW TO STAY IN
TOUCH WITH THERE'S WORK. MANY
OF THE BRUNT OF THE ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN AND BEEN LAID OFF FOR
HEATHER HOURS REDUCED. NOW
WORST OF ALL FOR THOSE TURNING
EIGHTEEN OR TO TWENTY ONE
DURING THE CRISIS THEY WILL.
CUT OFF FROM ESSENTIAL SERVICES
MAINTAIN HOUSING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES AND KEEP WITHOUT THEIR
EDUCATION. FORTUNATELY THEY ARE
NOT GIVEN THE NECESSARY
PROTECTIONS TO WHETHER THE
PRICES AND WITHOUT OUR SUPPORT-
LEFT ALONE TO DEAL WITH FOOD
AND HOUSING AND THIRTIES. WE
HAVE AN URGENCY TO PASS AS
FIFTY NINE ONE TWO AND STABLE
UPS PLACEMENTS HOUSING AND
SERVICE FOR FOSTER YOU. NON
DEPENDENCE TO THIS PANDEMIC IN
THE FUTURE STATE OF EMERGENCY.
THE BILL WILL BE IT'S THE- TURN
EIGHTEEN WILL BE ASSUME INTO
THE NON MY MINOR DEPENDENCE
SISTER. UNLESS THEY CHOOSE TO
OPT OUT- IT ALSO ENSURES THAT
THE USE WHO TURNED TWENTY ONE
DURING THE STATE REMAINS A WERE
MADE JUST AND STABLE PLACEMENT
TILL SIX MONTHS AFTER THE STATE
OF EMERGENCY CONCLUDES. AND
LASTLY IT CLOSE TO THE IS WHICH
PREVENTS SIR DO FROM ENTERING
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE AND I I'D
LIKE TO TAKE OVER THIS POINT TO
MY DISS MAN SURE- I BELIEVE WE
HAVE THE USE LAWCENTER JULIE
MCCORMICK. AND JOURNEY HOUSING
ADVOCATES ASHLEY WAS A RAGA OF
TO SPEAK KERN FOSTER YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER BELL A
WILL TO TWO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND YOU CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEES ONCE A
TWO TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY
ACCORDINGLY WITNESSES FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL ONLY BE
PERMITTED TOTAL MINUTES. ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
MEASURES MODERATOR DO WE- HAVE
ANY WITNESSES. THE RECORD
TESTIFIED YOUR TELEPHONE. THANK
YOU AND PLEASE PRESS ONE TEN
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. PLEASE PRESS
ONE TEN ZERO OR OPPOSITION.
MODERATOR THAT'S OF WITNESSES
HERE TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY VIA
TELEPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON JOINT.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU CHAIR
TACO AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU SENATOR BELL FOR
AUTHORING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION AND FOR YOUR
ONGOING COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING
THE LIVES OF YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE I'M JULIE MCCORMICK AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER OF CALIFORNIA CO
SPONSOR OF SB NINE TWELVE.
CHILDREN LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND CHILDREN UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE DEPENDENCY
COURT IN LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO
AND PLASTER COUNTY AND A OF
THOSE ALMOST THREE THOUSAND ARE
USING EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISI CREATED BY
CODE NINETEEN HAVE BROUGHT TO
LIGHT THE URGENT NEED TO ENACT
POLICIES THAT ONE SURE THE
TRANSITION AGE FOSTER YOUTH ARE
ABLE TO STAY SAFE. CABLE AND IN
SUPPORT OF PLACEMENTS DURING AN
EMERGENCY. BEFORE THE
GOVERNOR'S A ORDER AT FIFTY
THREE TWENTY MANY TRANSITION
AGE USE FEAR HAVING TO LEAVE
THEIR PROGRAMS. BECAUSE THEY
WERE TURNING TWENTY ONE OR NO
LONGER ABLE TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE. BECAUSE THEY LOST THEIR
JOBS. WHILE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WAS SHUT DOWN UNDER
STATE HOME ORDER THESE YOUTH
WERE FACING HOMELESSNESS. SB
NINE TWELVE ONE SURE THAT OUR
MOST VULNERABLE YOUTH ARE NOT
PUT IN THAT POSITION DURING
TIMES OF EMERGENCY. THAT THEY
ARE PUSHED OUT OF THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM. TIME WHEN SERVICE.
SUPPORTS ARE. DEAD AT TWELVE IS.
THE GOVERNMENT EXECUTIVE OR
WHICH IS TO EXPIRE ON JUNE
THIRTIETH. THIS LEGISLATION
WILL CONTINUE TO PROTECT. SEC
BY THE GOVERNOR BROADEN FOSTER
SAFETY NET. TO ENSURE THE OLDER
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE PROTECTED.
DURING OTHER CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCIES. HOUSTON FOSTER
CARE ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO THE CUTS IN
CRITICAL HOUSING EDUCATION
EMPLOYMENT SUPPORT.
SPECIFICALLY YOUTH NEARING
ADULTHOOD RED EXTREME. COMING
IN. LOSING EMPLOYMENT CAN BE
COMING HOMELESS. SB NINE 12-1
SURE THE TRANSITIONING CHOOSE
CAN CONTINUE TO RECEIVE
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE SUPPORT
DURING A STATE OF EMERGENCY
WITHOUT WORRYING ABOUT AGE AND
OR PARTICIPATION REQUIREMENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION THE
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER IS PROUD
TO CO SPONSOR SB NINE TWELVE
AND RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE ABOUT. I NOW
LIKE TO TURN THIS OVER TO
ASHLEY WAS RAGA LIFE EXPERIENCE
WILL DEMONSTRATE THE URGENT
NEED FOR THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. HELLO THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ASHLEY. ON THE CALL.
HELLO YES. PLEASE BEGIN GOOD
AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS ASHLEY I
HAVE YOUR ON BEHALF OF JOURNEY
HOW. AND NINE PAUL THAT HAS
PROVIDED DIRECTOR THE CURRENT
AND FORMER. ANGELES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THE LAST FIVE YEARS.
I AM A FORMER FASTER YOU-
HAVING INTERSCOPE RECORDS WITH
THEM AS A BABY AT THE AGE OF
ONE I LIVED IN FOR QUICKLY
BEFORE LANDING IN. PLACE LIKE
HOME I MEAN YOU FEEL A GRADUATE
AND AS OF TOMORROW WILL BE
GRADUATING FROM COLUMBIA
UNIVERSITY WITH MY MASTERS IN
SOCIAL WORK AND I'LL BE
PURSUING MY DOCTOR IN ALSO WORK
ALL UNIVERSITY OF WASHINGTON
SEATTLE. A LARGE LOCAL WITH
NINETEEN WITH THE COURT OF
CLAIMS THAT MAKE HELLO YOU
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS OF MAKING
THEIR UNIT ARMED WITH ADDED
URGENCY FOLLOWING LIGHTING AND
STUDENT HOUSING DYING. FROM
COMPLICATIONS. ASIAN URGENTLY
CAME TO IN ABOUT THE CAMP
FILLED WITH CARRYING. THEIR
BELONGINGS LOADING TO RETURN TO
THE THAT THEY CALL. REALLY
SIMILAR TO MANY STUDENT I DO
NOT HAVE SUCH SOME REAL. FOR
SIXTY YOUR EARLY. REALLY WE OUT
TO COST YOU KNOW LOOKING.
PROBABLY TOGETHER TO LOOK BACK.
BUT I CONSIDER MYSELF ONE OF
THE FEW LUCKY ONES COME IN
NINETEEN CUT SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON TRANSITION EACH YEAR. THE
CRISIS TRAINING NEARLY THIRTY
YET EVERY TIME THEY ARE
DESPERATE TO CREATE THE BILLION
FROM THE PATIENT. IT JUST
HOUSING YOU KNOW CRIER THE
CRISIS. AROUND THIRTY IN A BOX
YOU HELD FOR IN THE CORNER
CLINIC IN LONG GOT LEGAL
ADDITIONAL. GOING HEALTHCARE OR
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL THE GOVERNOR
ACTED QUICKLY TO PROTECT THOSE
EATING OUT DURING THE CRISIS.
AND EMPLOY THE STATE TO
ESTABLISH THE SAME PROTECTION
LONG TERM FUTURE STATE OF
EMERGENCY. EMPLOYMENT MANY COST
YOU'D HAVE HAD HOURS OF
EMPLOYMENT SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCED OR JOB LEMONADE
ALTOGETHER. AND UNFORTUNATELY
NOT ALL COST USE THAT ARE
LOSING THEIR JOBS- ELIGIBLE FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS.
ESPECIALLY IF THEY WORK PART
TIME OR HAVE WILL EACH WORK.
LAST WEEK AND MANY OF THE
QUESTION IT OF CONNOR AND
INSTABILITY FASTER AND EARLY IN
LIFE MANY FALSE. YOU HAVE. IF
THE- IN NINETEEN HAVE ADDED
THAT IN LIKE THIRTY. GRADING
AND- ONE OF THE HOLE. WITHOUT
THE OF SUPPORT AND IN LOVED
ONES. SB NINE TWELVE THIS
BATTLE AND PROVIDE STABILITY TO
THE CSHIER AGING DURING OF
EMERGENCY A GLOBAL AND- WELL
WILD. BUT YOU CANNOT RISK BEING.
DURING SUCH CRISIS THEY NEED
THE ASSURANCE FROM THE EIGHT
THEY CAN WEATHER THE STORMS
BEFORE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT
THIS MOMENT WILL GOING TO
PUBLIC COMMENT- ONCE AGAIN ALL
THOSE WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WAS SOME OF THE
COMMENTS TO THE NAME
AFFILIATION A POSITION ON THE
MASS MEASURES PHONE NUMBER IS.
1-877-336-4441 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS FIVE NINE ZERO FOUR
THREE FIVE FIVE. ARE THERE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN ROOM
FORTY TWO WITH THE WHO WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT AND
SUPPORT OF S. H. IN TWELVE.
THANK WE TURN TO LIKE. AT THIS
MOMENT WE WILL MOVE ON TO.
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY%
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE TWELVE
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
TWELVE. WE WILL BEGIN. THANK.
NINE ONE ZERO FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JESSICA
BARTOLO AT THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY I APOLOGIZE
I WASN'T ABLE TO GET A LETTER
IN BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MODERATE KEEP ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE THREE. NEXT RETURNS TO
LINE OF ONE ZERO EIGHT PLEASE
CALL. COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TURKEY AGUILAR
DIRECTOR STATEWIDE POLICY
AGENDA. HOW COLD BUDGET OF THE
SB NINE TWELVE- ALSO WILL LIST
A LIST OF PARTNERS THE- WHO ARE
SOME SUPPORT. LIST PLEASE SEND
IT OUT WRITERS. YEAH BROUGH
GUARDIANS PROGRAM THE UCLA
BRUINS VENTO. THE CHARACTER AND
THE FEMINIST FOUND. ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THE NATIONAL.
RETURN TO LINE OF ONE ONE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BECKY GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT RETURN
KLEIN OF ONE ONE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU NEED TO BRING A FOUR
DAY FROM THE YOU LAW CENTER
EXPRESSING STRONG SUPPORT ON
BEHALF OF ITSELF AND THE
FOLLOWING COALITION OF
SUPPORTERS CHILDREN NOW. UNDER
FOR YOU LAW JOHNBURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOU PUBLIC
COUNCIL THE CENTER FOR JUVENILE
ON POLICY AND THE CHILDREN'S
ADVOCACY INSTITUTE THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER LINES IN
Q. PLEASE PRESS ONE TEN ZERO.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
THE LINE JUST ONCE AGAIN. JUST
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE HEARD FROM
ALL THE SUPPORT WITNESSES ON SB
NINE TWELVE. YES THANK YOU
MA'AM. PLEASE PRESS ONE TEN
ZERO TO SHOW SUPPORT. DO WE
HAVE MODERATE DO WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING. WE
HAVE ONE PERSON WAITING NOW WE
MAY PROCEED. MODERATOR WE MAY
PROCEED ON ANY- WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT TO SB NINE TWELVE.
ASIAN PLEASE PRESS ONE TEN ZERO
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT.
ARE WE TURN TO LINE OF ONE ONE
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME HAS BEEN AND
RAFAEL AND I'M A STUDENT AT UC
RIVERSIDE. FOUR SB NINE TALK.
AND WE HAVE FURTHER NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU AT THIS
MOMENT WE WILL DO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE TWELVE ARE THERE ANY-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY OR CALL. I HEARING
ROOM FORTY FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE. AND FOR OUR POSITION
PLEASE PRESS. SCENE NINE ARE
THERE- ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY. IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE TWELFTH.
WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WHEN TO TESTIFY VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS FUND
AND ZERO FOR OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
PROVIDE ME THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION NO LINES IN Q. THANK
YOU. I IF YOU WOULD PLEASE JUST.
IN UP THE LINES ONCE AGAIN AND
FOR OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
TWELVE. BOB WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE. OUR COMMENT
THEIR POSITION. MODERATOR. OKAY
DO AT THIS MOMENT WILL MOVE ON
TO MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
WELL WE'LL START WITH SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU IN THE SENATE
BILL AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I DID HAVE A
BRIEF QUESTION RELATED TO THE
ANALYSIS- THERE WAS- AN
ANALYSIS THEY DID MAKE
REFERENCE TO- SECTION
REGARDING- I GUESS W. I. C.
THREE EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT WHICH
AROUND THE- RIVAS IT'S ACCESS
TO EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENT FOR SEGMENT OF
TRANSITIONAL. AGE YOUTH
POPULATION THAT'S BEEN
CONSIDERED. LEGISLATION SO I
DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER YOU ARE
PLAN TO CONTINUE FOR THAT
LANGUAGE IN YOUR BILL OR- PER
DAY ANALYSIS- YOU WERE GOING TO.
PERHAPS PULL THAT BACK I JUST-
DID BE HELPFUL TO UNDERSTAND
WATER. WHAT WHAT THE WHAT WHAT
YOUR KIDS ARE TALKING WHICH
SECTION REFERRING TO SO THIS
IS- IT'S AND THIS ISON PAGE
TWELVE TWELVE AND ANALYSIS IS
ACTUALLY THE- LAST PARAGRAPH
THERE WAS- A SUGGESTION ABOUT
REMOVING. AND THE BILL THE
WORKMEN MINTS TO. W. I. C.
THREE EIGHT EIGHT- AND- I JUST
DIDN'T KNOW WHETHER THAT WAS.
FIND ADDRESS THAT YOU ARE. OF
THAT WAS BROUGHT AN ANALYSIS WE
WERE NOT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
ADDRESS THAT BUT- WILL BE
CONSIDERED AND- BETWEEN NOW AND
THE- NEXT OF. APPROPRIATE JR
OKAY OKAY WELL WE HAVEN'T
LOOKED AT THAT YET BUT WE WILL
YEAH OKAY WELL I MEAN CERTAINLY
I THINK IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL ON BEHALF IN A MOVE THAT
APPROPRIATE TIME. IS. SENATE
JACKSON I WANTED TO SECOND THAT
THE THOUGHT THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND I DON'T SEE ANY
REASON- OTHER THAN THE CURRENT
EMERGENCY THAT WE COULDN'T
EXTEND THIS BEYOND THAT FOR
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND I WANT
TO GIVE A SPECIAL SHOUT OUT TO
THE YOUNG LADY WHO SPOKE TO US
WHO'S GETTING HER MASTER'S
DEGREE- PRESENTLY AT COLUMBIA
PLEASE STAY SAFE NEW YORK CITY
IS IN A BIT OF A HOT SPOT- BUT
I JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU A
SHOW OUT BECAUSE A IT'S THESE
WONDERFUL STORIES OF THESE
FOLKS ABLE TO OVERCOME SOME
SHOULD. THE INSTRUMENT BY TO
CHEAT GREAT THINGS AND I JUST-
WANT TO EXPRESS MY-
APPRECIATION FOR YOUR HARD WORK
AND- ALSO TO SENATOR BELL WHO'S
BEEN A BIG ADVOCATE FOR FOSTER
YOUTH SO WITH THAT I'LL BE
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU ANY ADDITIONAL FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS BILL. NOW
OKAY SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR PENN AND ANOTHER MOTION
BY SENATE JACKSON. SO LET'S A
COMPLETE DEBATE. SENATOR BELL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES IN
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS SINCE WE
PASSED A. B. TWELVE AND SIGNED
INTO LAW BY GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER- MANY FOSTER
YOUTH OF AGE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
ONE AND BE ON THE BENEFITTED
FROM OF THE TRANSITION PERIOD
AS NON NOT NONE MINOR
DEPENDENT. AND WE'VE REALLY
INCREASED- THE- THE SUCCESS OF
THOSE FOSTER YOU THIS BILL WILL
CONTINUE THEIR OUT AND ALLOW
THEM TO HAVE THE SUCCESS
CONTINUE WELL WE GO THROUGH THE
USE OF. OR WILL CRISIS TAT
WERE RENDON AND I REGION I VOTE
AND I HOPE THAT X. ACCEPTED AS
AN URGENCY MATTER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PELL AT THIS
MOMENT- SECRETARY DO YOU CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
NINE ONE TWO BELL THE MOTION IS
DEEPAK. SENATOR HER DAUGHTER.
HI I JONES I'VE. BELL BELL I.
JACKSON ALL RIGHT JACKSON I.
MELENDEZ AYE MELENDEZ AYE PAN
HI AND I WIENER. RIGHT WIENER I
STEP SEVEN ZERO. SO THE BOOK IS
SEVEN ZERO AND THE BILL IS OUT.
RIGHT UP NEXT. WE HAVE OUR SB.
TEN SIXTY FIVE WALKED HIM
SENATOR HERTZBERG. PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT YOUR BILL WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU I DO
THIS BECAUSE I. I HAVE A ONE
YEAR OF- THANK YOU EVERYONE
APPRECIATE APPRECIATE THE TIME
AND- AS A NUMBER OF NOT MEMBERS
KNOW WITH WHOM I HAVE SPOKEN.
OF LIMITED MY BILL BLOATED
CURRENTLY THIS IS IT. AND THIS
IS IT BECAUSE ARMED YOU KNOW
MAYBE AS WE MOVE FORWARD ON
SOME OF THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
PACKAGES YOU MAY SEE ME AND
VARIOUS COMMITTEES BUT- THE
PURPOSE HERE IS TO REALLY
SMOOTH THE WAY FOR CAO WORKS
FAMILIES- TO RECEIVE ASSISTANCE
WHEN THEY'RE FACING
HOMELESSNESS. EXCEPT THE- AND
SO FORTH. SERIES THEM IS QUITE
A TECHNICAL BILL BUT YOU KNOW
HERE'S THE UNDERLYING
ARCHITECTURE HERE'S THE VERY
HUMAN PROBLEM THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO FACE. BUT WE HAVE IN TWO
THOUSAND. ALMOST SERVICE THIS
POINT IN TIME COUNT ESTIMATED
EIGHT THOUSAND FAMILIES AND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND CHILDREN WERE
HOMELESS IN CALIFORNIA.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND THROUGHOUT THIS
LEGISLATURE THAT THAT IS JUST
COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE. IS
WHAT WE'VE DONE IS GIVEN THESE
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES THAT
INFORM SO MUCH OF THE DEBATE
LEAVE DRAMATICALLY ALL OF US IN
IN THIS HOUSE IN THE OTHER HALF
TO DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF BILLS TO FOCUS ON.
VIRGIN MATTER PARTICULARLY
THOSE RELATED WITH. AND THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. IT MAY READ
BEFORE IT IS. COMMITTEE TO
SAFELY HOUSE CHILDREN IN THEIR
WITH THEIR FAMILIES BY MAKING
SMALL YET MEANINGFUL
IMPROVEMENTS THE COW WORKS
HOMELESSNESS ASSISTANCE PROJECT
I WAS HERE WHEN. THE ON ERIN. A
PROGRAM YOUR ROOM AND I BELIEVE
SENATOR OUT OF THAT STILL THE
CASE BUT SHE'S AN- UNBELIEVABLE
PUBLIC SERVANT. NOPE NOPE ONLY
BE WITHOUT ESPECIALLY DURING
THIS TIME OF PANDEMIC AND
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY. YOU CAN
SEE ALLEN TO SET FORTH A NUMBER
OF TIMELINE CHANGES. ASSIST
JUST THAT LOW THERE'S ALL.
STATUTORY LEVEL BUT THERE ACE
OF WHAT'S IT LIKE TO BE A HUMAN
BEING AND INTERFACING WITH YOUR
GOVERNMENT WHEN YOU'RE UNDER
SUCH EXTRAORDINARY SIR DANCE SO
I HAVE TO WHICH IS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE TODAY YOU JUST
HEARD WITH RESPECT TO CENTER
BELLS MEASURE CREDIT JESSICA
BARTOLO WESTERN CENTER. ON LAW
AND- STENA. PASCUCCI CURRENTLY
IN THIS CAPACITY FOR TESTIFYING
TODAY WILL BE TESTIFYING AS A
JUNIOR LEAGUE OF LOS ANGELES
WHO'S IN STRONG SUPPORT AND
PULLED ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF
THIS MATTER SO WITH THAT. I'D
LIKE TO TURN TO. BARTOLO. AND
WE DO HAVE TWO WITNESSES ON THE
LINE. WE HAVE TO THE CARPARK
LOW. AND CRISTINA BESEECHING.
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES. CRISTINA LINE IS
OPEN- I DO NOT SHOULD JUST COME
ON THE LINE YEP JESSICA'S.
MODERATOR WE HAVE JESSICA
BARCELONA LINE. I DO NOT HAVE
JESSICA BUT WE ARE WOULD HAVE-
CRISTINA OKAY CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR CRISTINA.
IN A LINE. THANK YOU SO MUCH HI
SENATOR I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PUBLIC SERVICE AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME
CRISTINA HAS YOU AND I'M
THINKING ON BEHALF OF AN EQUAL
FIFTY FIVE CO SPONSORED THE
JUNIOR LEAGUE OF LOS ANGELES OR
J. L. L. A. B. WE ARE A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF ABOUT A
THOUSAND WOMEN IN THE LA AREA
AND WE FOCUS ON THE NEEDS. OF.
DR AT PARTY JAIL A AND ON THE
STATE PUBLIC AFFAIRS MAYBE.
ALSO KNOWN AS FAST AND WE
ANALYZE LEGISLATION ADVOCATE
WITH YEARLY WOMEN ACROSS STATE
RECORD ONE EIGHT EIGHT THOUSAND
WOMEN. I AM NOT EXPERIENCE
WHERE THE- INCIDENT ALSO
THROUGH MY DAY JOB AS A
JOURNALIST FOR A LOS ANGELES
WITH THE NEW STATION. WE HAVE
SEEN THE CASUALTIES FROM
LOOPHOLES IN THE SYSTEM.
IMAGINE A SINGLE MOTHER. IT WAS
ONE PAYCHECK AWAY. FROM BEING
HOMELESS. IT AND SHE WALKED JOB
THE GAP THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS
LIKE HOW WERK PROGRAM THE LACK
OF A HOST NOT YOUR- COULD
RESULT IN HER FAMILY LIVING THE-
ONE LOOK AT THE COLOR HOUSE. OF
WHICH OVER 90% ARE NOT HEADING
WITH MALE CHILDREN OVER TWELVE
YEARS OLD. ACT HOUSEHOLDS THAT
ARE ON. SPLIT UP AT AGE TO GO
TO SHELTER BOY OVERSEE AGE HOW
DESPERATELY FROM WHEN OFTEN. AS
HE TURNED SIXTY FIVE HELLO THIS
THAT GAP THAT THAT FAMILY
DOESN'T GET YOU BETWEEN.
SPLITTING UP OR LIVING ON THE
STREET. AT THE COURTS CHILDREN
SO THEY CAN FOCUS ON THEIR
EDUCATION IT RATHER THAN.
THEY'RE GOING TO SLEEP AT
NIGHT. SB TEN SIXTY FIVE IS
JUST COMMON AND BUILD A JUNIOR
LEAGUE OF LOS ANGELES FIELD IT
MORE NEEDED NOW DURING THIS CAN
MAKE. EVER AND WE KILEY REQUEST
AND I THOUGHT. YEAH THANK YOU
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE A WITNESS-
JESSICA BOTTLE ON THE LINE. BUT
THIS TIME THEY DO NOT HAVE JUST
COME ON THE LINE. A WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROCEED WITH THE
WITHOUT JESSICA IF IT'S SOME
POINT YOU CAN ADD ON THE LINE
GIVEN THE TECHNICAL CHALLENGES.
AT APPRECIATED BUT CERTAINLY I
WOULD PROCEED WITH OTHERS AND
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
QUESTIONS HAPPY TO DO SO. OKAY
SO AT THIS POINT WE WILL GOING
TO PUBLIC COMMENT TO AND ONCE
AGAIN WE'D- LIKE TO LIMIT. TO
THE TEST ONE TWO THREE MINUTES
PLEASE TEACHER- NAME
AFFILIATION OF POSITION ONCE
AGAIN THE PHONE NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN THREE THREE
SIX FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. FIVE NINE ZERO
FOUR THREE FIVE FIVE. AND WE
WILL BEGIN WITH PUBLIC COMMENT
TO ROOM FOUR TWO TWO ZERO THREE
IS THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT. OF
THIS BILL SB TEN SIXTY FIVE IN
ROOM FOUR TWO ZERO THREE. NO
FEE NONE WE WILL MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF.
SB TEN SIXTY FIVE IN- OUR
TELEPHONE LINE. YEAH THIS IS
KEVIN AS MILLION. YOU HEAR ME
YES. YEAH OKAY OKAY YEAH I'M
SORRY THIS KIND OF WEIRD BUT
YEAH WE ALSO ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF DECISIONS A VERY
FUNDAMENTAL BILL ESPECIALLY THE
CORPORATE BANKING AREA AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M HONORED IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PRINT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF. SB. TEN SIXTY
FIVE. WE WILL BEGIN ONLY IF YOU
ARE IN OR- PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU A NUMBER THEN
I WILL ANNOUNCE YOUR NUMBER ONE
ARE READY FOR YOUR COMMENTS.
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
YES AT THIS TIME WE HAVE FIVE
THAT ARE IN SUPPORT. OKAY THANK
YOU MODERATE AB WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES. SO
FIRST WE GO TO NUMBER ONE
TWENTY SIX ONE TWO SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THE NEXT WE WILL GO
TO NUMBER ONE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
YOUR OPEN. THE LECTURE NOT ON
MUTE NUMBER ONE TWENTY. THE
NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER ONE
TWENTY FOUR ONE TWENTY FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. HI GOOD EVENING THIS
IS JERD CALL WITH CALIFORNIA
THROUGH POLICY ADVOCATE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER ONE NO THREE ONE OH
THREE YOU ARE OPEN. I'M JAMIE
SHAPIRO FROM JAIL A AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF SB AND SIXTY FIVE.
AND LASTLY WE GO TO LINE ONE OH
FOUR ONE OH FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
HI KIMBERLY OFF BACKING WITH
JUNIOR LEAGUE OF LOS ANGELES
AND I'M IN PART OF THAT. FIVE
NO ONE KILO BACK TO LINE ONE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY YOU ARE OPEN.
I'M SURE MEMBERS DEMóCRATAS
FROM MERRILL WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
ALL. WATER DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL. BUT PEOPLE ON THE
LINE. BUT WE DID HAVE ONE MORE
COME IN- SO I LAST ONE- WE WILL
GO TO LINE ONE THIRTY ONE
THIRTY YOU ARE OPEN. HI SENATOR
MEMBERS OF THE MILLIONS OF
MONEY ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL ASSOCIATION OUR
APOLOGIES BUT DIDN'T HAVE A
CHANCE TO GET OUR- LETTER IN IN
TIME BUT WE JUST DRIVE UP. OKAY
AT THIS MOMENT ARE WE WILL MOVE
ON TO PUBLIC COMMENT AND
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN SIXTY FIVE
ARE IN NEED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
FOUR- FORTY TWO OR THREE I
APOLOGIZE WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMON IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TEN SIXTY FIVE. THE NONE ARE
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS. IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN SIXTY FIVE
ON THE TELEPHONE LINE. AND IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. N.
ONE ZERO IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MODERATE
CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE ZERO IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY THANK YOU- CAN
YOU JUST CHECK THE LINES ONE
MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL OPPOSITION ON SB
TEN SIXTY FIVE. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. MODERATE DO WE
HAVE ANY INTO ANY INDIVIDUALS.
AND THE QUEUE AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE- NOBODY IN THE QUEUE THANK
YOU. DO ANY MEMBERS OF IT SO
THIS ONE WILL MOVE ON TO A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS DOES ANYONE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR. THE BILL. OKAY WELL
THANK YOU- WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SO SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
JUST WANT TO THE NOTICE IN THE
FRONT ROW HERE TO IT WELCOME
OUR NEWEST SENATOR. WELCOME TO
THE SENATE AND GET CHEST
YESTERDAY WHEN SWORN IN.
WELCOME ABOARD- TO SENATE. AND
JUST TO THANK EVERYBODY AND
THANK THIS COMMITTEE FOR THE
KIND OF WORK DID YOU DO I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH. THESE ARE
HUGELY IMPORTANT KINDS OF
MEASURES. THAT REALLY HAVE ON
THE FRONTLINE IMPACT PEOPLE'S
LIVES. IN THE MOST DIRECT IN
DRAMATIC WAYS AND WITH THAT. I
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. RIVAL
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATE BILL TEN SIXTY
FIVE BY HERTZBERG THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HER
TITLE. BY THE PHOTO I JONES HI
BROWN'S FIVE BELL. BELL FIVE
JACKSON ALL RIGHT. JACKSON AYE
MELENDEZ AYE MELENDEZ AYE. CAN
BUY AN ONLINE WINNER WIENER I
THAT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COMMITTEE AND CHAIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH. SO UP UP NEXT WE
HAVE SENATOR JONES. THE. LONG.
ACTUALLY AT THIS TIME WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SECRETARY CAN
NIGHT YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB EIGHT EIGHT TWO WINNER THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS SB ONE TWO FIVE
NINE HER TADO THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND SB ONE TWO
SIX FOUR HER TOP HER TITLE THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. MEMBERS DO WE
HAVE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SO MOVED. OKAY
WE HAVE MOTION BY CENTER PAN
AND A COUPLE SECONDS SO. AS
SECRETARY MAY PROCEED. HER
TITLE. HI ALTHOUGH I JONES
THANK JONES BY BELL. BELL I
JACKSON HI JACKSON I'M
MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ AYE PAN HI.
PAN AYE WIENER AYE WIENER AYE
THAT SEVEN ZERO. SO I. CAN
THINK CHALLENGER HAS A SEVEN
ZERO VOTE. WHAT CAN. UP NEXT WE
HAVE SB. ONE TWO ZERO TWO.
WELCOME SENATOR JONES FEEL FREE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL WHEN YOU
ALREADY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SENATE BILL TWO OR TWO WILL
GRANT OUT FUNDS TO NON PROFITS
TO CREATE EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS. IT IS NO SECRET
THAT CALIFORNIA IS FACING A
HOMELESS CRISIS IS ALSO NO
SECRET THE CALIFORNIA WE FACING
UNPRECEDENTED ECONOMIC CRISIS
BECAUSE OF COVERT NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA'S UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
IS PROJECTED TO SKYROCKET PAST
EIGHTEEN PERCENT. SB TWO OR TWO
WILL FUND PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS
ON DEVELOPING JOB SKILLS AND
BUILDING WORK EXPERIENCE THIS
WILL GIVE HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO SECURE
EMPLOYMENT AND EVENTUALLY THE
ABILITY TO LIFT THEMSELVES OUT
OF HOMELESSNESS. THIS BILL
ADDRESS BOTH CALIFORNIA'S
HOMELESSNESS AND ECONOMIC
CRISIS I BELIEVE THAT I HAVE
KIM STONE ON THE GENERAL
SUPPORT PHONE LINE WHEN YOU'RE
READY FOR TESTIMONY THANK YOU
THAT'S MY OPENING REMARKS.
THANK YOU CENTER JONES- DO WE
HAVE TO WITNESSES ON THE LINE.
IT LOOKS LIKE A SMALL WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY WITNESSES. ON THE LINE.
REVIEW TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THAT OKAY GREAT. OKAY SO AT
THIS MOMENT WE WILL GO WITH-
PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE AGAIN DUE
TO THE CONSTRAINTS- WE WILL
LIMIT TO A TESTIMONY TO THREE
MINUTES. AND WE WILL GO WITH-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
TWO ZERO TWO IN A ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE. SEE NONE DO WE
HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF A ONE TWO ZERO TWO ON THE
TELEPHONE LINE. BUT YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME AGAIN ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MODERATE CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
A YES AT THIS TIME WE HAVE ONE
THAT IS IN Q. THANK YOU. YOU
MAY PROCEED. I WILL GO TO
NUMBER ONE THIRTY TO ONE THIRTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
CARE A NUMBER THIS IS KIM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ASSOCIATED
BUILDERS AND CONTRACTORS
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTER.
WHEREIN SUPPORT OF THE SENATE
BILL BARBECUE. ABC NOR CAL
PARTNERS WITH GROUPS LIKE THE
SALVATION ARMY TO PROVIDE JOB
SKILLS TRAINING AND TO GIVE
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING FOR
FORMERLY HOMELESS PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO GAIN SKILLS TO WORK IN
THE TRADE. YEAH WE PARTNER WITH
THE ARE THE FACT. YEAH A
DIFFERENT CONSTRUCTION
LEADERSHIP TRAINING PROGRAM
GRADUATES ABOUT FORTY TWO PER
YEAR PROVIDE YOU WITH A
COMPREHENSIVE INTERACTION
CONSTRUCTION TRADES AS A CAREER
PATH. COME FROM OTHER
RETIREMENT PROGRAMS OR SERVICES
WITH THE BOTH CONTROL YOU. ALSO
OKAY. AND TRAINING ELECTRICAL
CARPET YOU TRADE. CORD COLOR
THAT THE CEREMONY AND A JOB
FAIR FOR TREATMENT EIGHTY NOR
CAL COMPANIES PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT COULD WRAPPED BUT THE
DIGITAL FINE. THEREFORE WE
SUPPORT SENATE BILL TWELVE OH
TWO ENTER YOUR EYES OUT. THANK
YOU. OUR MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN- TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB ONE TWO ZERO TWO.
A ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
RIGHT NOW. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO FURTHER IN THE QUEUE. THANK
YOU- AT THIS POINT AT THIS
MOMENT WILL GO ON TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO SB ONE
TWO ZERO TWO DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB ONE TWO ZERO TWO AND FORTY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO ZERO THREE.
CNN WILL MOVE ON TO. ANY
WITNESSES OPPOSED TO SB ONE TWO
ZERO TWO. ARE ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE. ON THE PHONE IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WAITING TO. ON THE
LINE. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NOBODY IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU
OKAY. CAN YOU MODERATE A CAN
YOU CHECK JUST ONE MORE TIME.
IF THERE'S ANY MEMBERS OF THE
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB ONE
TWO ZERO TWO. ABSOLUTELY ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. NOW DO
WE HAVE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
OKAY SO WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS AT THE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FOR THE ALL. ALL RIGHT OF.
SENATOR JONES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THIRD AT THANK YOU SB
TOWARD TO WILL FUND A NONPROFIT
SO THAT THEY CAN TEACH ALMOST
INDIVIDUALS IMPORTANT JOB
SKILLS AND PREPARE THEM FOR A
FUTURE OF ECONOMIC STABILITY I
APPRECIATE THE MOTION ASKED.
ABOUT. THANK YOU SENATOR JOHN
WE HAVE A MOTION I BELIEVE BY
SENATOR PENN FAN. AND SET
CENTER MELENDEZ AT MY APOLOGIES
AND- WILL GO HEAD AND SECRETARY
IF YOU DON'T IF YOU CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SB ONE. TWO BY
JONES THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS HER
TADO. AYE AUTO ARE FURTADO I'D
JONES HI JONES II BELL. BELL I
JACKSON HI JACKSON AYE AM
MELINDA'S AYE MELENDEZ AYE PAN
HI. AND I AM WIENER. WIENER AYE
SEVEN ZERO. THE VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO IN THAT ILL IS OUT. UP
NEXT WE HAVE- SB ONE TWO THREE
TWO BY SENATOR GLAZER. SENATOR
GLAZER WILL PRESENT SB ONE TWO
THREE TO REMOTELY UP CENTER
GLAZER WHEN YOU'RE READY-
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGAN UP
BEFORE THEN PLEASE MAKE SURE
THAT YOUR PHONES AND COMPUTERS
ARE ON- MUTE OUR IT PERSONNEL
WILL MUTE AND UNMUTE THE VIDEO
SERVICE WHEN YOU WISH TO SPEAK.
THIS WILL AID IN ELIMINATED ANY
ACROSS FEET AT THE TIME YOU
COMMON TRICK QUESTION USE A
RAZOR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. A WELCOME SENATOR
GLAZERS. ZERO THANK YOU CHAIR
HER TITLE PRITCHETT VERY MUCH I
WANT TO START OFF BY THANKING
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL AND PLEASE TO ACCEPT THE
CANADIAN ADVANCE THIS BILL
ALLOWS STUDENTS PARENTS ON CAL
WORKS TO CONTINUE RECEIVING
FULL BENEFITS THROUGH THE
PROGRAM AS LONG AS THEY REMAIN
IN GOOD ACADEMIC. THE BILL
REQUIRES COUNTY DEPARTMENTS
REVISED THE STUDENTS PARENTS
WITH FUNDS TO PURCHASE THIS
PRIOR TO THE BEGINNING OF THEIR
ACADEMIC TERM. CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS HAS EXACERBATED.
BARRIERS COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE
FACING TODAY. AS EVERYONE KNOWS
STUDENTS ARE EXPERIENCING
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OF HOUSING
AND FOOD AND SECURITY. MAKING A
COLLEGE EDUCATION LESS
ACCESSIBLE ESPECIALLY FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. THIS BILL WILL
RELIEVE PRESSURE ON STUDENT
PARENTS ESPECIALLY DURING THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES ALLOW MORE CAL
WORKS APPLICANTS AND RECIPIENTS
TO ACHIEVE THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND PROFESSIONAL
GOALS. IT'S SUPPORTED BY A
BROAD COALITION OF STUDENT
GROUPS AND ANTI POVERTY
ORGANIZATIONS AND IS IMPORTANT
BILL TO HELP THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION OF STUDENTS THAT ARE
IN OUR GOTTEN WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOL
TODAY I'M PLEASED TO PASS THAT
WE HAVE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
FAVOR KEVIN. ARE SLIDING FROM
THE TWENTY COALITION A WELFARE
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION. JOANNE
REYES WALTZ IN A PHD CANDIDATE
AT UCLA THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU. OUR MODERATOR WE
HAVE- THE WITNESSES ON THE LINE
FOR THE NAMES OF KEVIN AND
JOANNA. YEAH AND JOE AND. SEVEN
MILLION COASTAL CALIFORNIA WHAT
PROVIDES ORGANIZATION WE THANK
YOU ALSO FOR THE BILL AND FOR
ALL TO READ THE BILL THAT WHAT
THE- THIS BILL WILL HELP WITH
DAUGHTER. HOW MOMS WHO ARE
TRYING TO BECOME SELF
SUFFICIENT BUYING A BARKING
UPON THE WORLD A MAJOR CHANGE
IN. WHICH IS ONE OF THE BEST
WAYS TO BECOME SELF SUFFICIENT.
SOME OF THE- HI TO THEIR ROOMS
THAT OUR STUDENTS ENTERED
SHOULD NOTED ALL MAKES. THAT
THEY HAVE BOOKS WILL BEGIN
PLANTS THE BOOKS TWO WEEKS FOR
COLLEGE BECAUSE TO THE YOUR
REPORTER STUDENTS WHO HAVE HAD
TO DROP OUT OF SCHOOL BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THE FOLKS ON PINE AND
JUST JUST GIVE THEM A FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR LOAN- VANCE. NOT
LOUNGE. FOR BOOKS. THANK YOU
ALL. WHAT THAT MEANT THE COULD.
THOUSAND FOOT THE STUDENT.
ACTUALLY CALLED SEATS FIVE
HUNDRED. CHOOSE A EVIDENCE YOU
NEED TO THE FULL WE HAVE COURSE
BUT- AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR AND
WE SHOULD YES SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL THANK YOU. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYBODY MY NAME IS
JOANNA RADIUS WALTER I'M A PHD
CANDIDATE UCLA AND I'M ALSO A
FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE DO AND
SINGLE MOTHER TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY TWO. I
RETURN OF MY PHD IS THE WAY OUT
OF FINANCIAL UNCERTAINTY AND TO
BEGIN A PATH TO A BETTER LIFE
FOR MY FAMILY. IN MY GRADUATE
EDUCATION HOWEVER I. PEOPLE
FINANCIAL BEERS FUNDING FOR
GRAD STUDENTS PROHIBITS WORKING
OUTSIDE JOBS IT'S NOT ADJUSTED
FOR FAMILY SIZE AND IT'S BARELY
ABOVE THE POVERTY LINE. MY
FAMILY HOUSING APARTMENT IS
CURRENTLY 90% 9% OF MY
STATEMENT A WHITE MAN- BUT MANY
OF MY FELLOW APPEARED ON THE
SINGLE MOTHER OF COLOR TRYING
TO FIX IT COOL AND OF THE
PARENTS TO TWO YOUNG CHILDREN.
ON WELFARE I RELY ON CALPERS
ENOUGH NUTRITION TO DO IT
MYSELF AND MY CHILDREN AND THEY
RECEIVE HEALTH COVERAGE THROUGH
MEDICARE AL BECAUSE DEPENDENT
COVERAGE THROUGH MY UNIVERSITY.
AT I'D LIKE TO TELL AS WELL BUT
I WOULD DENIED AND I STILL KNOW.
I'M THE PROCESS OF APPLYING TO
THE BENEFITS OF ARGUE WITH THE
RISK WITH A- AND WOULD. NO
RECORD AND- SPEAKING WITH
PARENTS WHO I KNOW THAT BECAUSE
WE ARE BENEFITS I'VE LEARN THAT
STAYING ON HOW WE'RE CUMPLIR AN
EVEN MORE. I DO STANDS IF I
WORK THAT YET I WOULD NEED TO
PHYSICALLY REPORT TO THE COUNTY
WELFARE DEPARTMENT EVERY TIME
MY CLASS SCHEDULE CHANGES EVERY
TIME I TAKE. A DIFFERENT CLASS
AND EVERY TIME THERE'S A SINGLE
CHANGE ANYTHING REGARDING MY
ACADEMIC RECORDS. AND FRIEND
SHARED THAT THE MONITORING
REQUIREMENTS OPENED HER UP TO
DISCRIMINATION A PROFESSOR AT
BERKELEY EXPRESSED DISDAIN FOR
WELFARE RECIPIENTS. YOU CAN
HARDLY IMAGINE HOW MUCH OF THE
BURDEN OF EXTRA STEPS PLACE ME
AND MY TEACHERS WHO BETWEEN
SUPPORTING OUR FAMILY AND
PURSUING RIGHT. AND DON'T
REALLY HAVE THE TIME TO
NAVIGATE THESE KINDS OF
BARRIERS. I'M NOT QUITE THE
PART AT THE TOP. TWO BUT I'M
SURE THAT DIDN'T PARENTS LIKE
MY CAN RECEIVE THE MUCH NEED
BENEFITS OF CAL WORKS AND BE
ABLE TO FOCUS ON OUR EDUCATION
AT. PATHWAY OF UPPER CUANDO THE
AND KEY TO MOVING OUT OF THE
WATER SYSTEM FOR GUIDE TO BE A
GOOD STUDENT A GOOD PARENT AND
TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON I SUPPORT
THE TOP THREE TWO AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS IN NEED. A
CLEANING FOR CALLS COMMITTEE
SOLICITUDE. TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. AT TWO THREE MINUTES
OF BOTH FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
ALL OTHERS WE SHOULD PROVIDE
PUBLIC TIME A SOME OF THE
COMMENTS TO THE NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION- WE WILL.
GO AHEAD AND- MOVED TO- PUBLIC
COMMENT. IN SUPPORT. OF SB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO. ONCE AGAIN
THE PAWN. ONCE AGAIN THE PHONE
NUMBER IS 1-877-336-4441 AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. FIVE NINE
ZERO FOUR THREE FIVE FIVE.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY ONE IN
THE QUEUE. ALI JOHN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. AND
AT THIS TIME IT LOOKS LIKE WE
DO HAVE- SIX THAT ARE IN THE
QUEUE. HI THERE WE GO AND START
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER ONE TWENTY
SIX ONE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BACK TO DEVELOP NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THEN NEXT WE WILL GO TO NUMBER
ONE HUNDRED ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND THIS IS HILLARY
NINE FROM THE ASSOCIATED
STUDENTS OF UC IRVINE AND WERE
IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE NUMBER NINETY SEVEN NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EVERYBODY POSH ON THE TRACK THE
PHONE RELATIONS DIRECTOR WITH
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION ON
AND USE HIS HE'S PROUD TO BE A
CO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT. A NEXT
WILL GO TO NUMBER ONE THIRTY
ONE ONE THIRTY ONE YOU ARE.
NUMBER ONE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI SORRY MY AND HAD AN
ISSUE WITH MY PHONE- THIS IS
RANCHO CAITLYN- FROM THE
ASSOCIATE STUDENT AT UC DAVIS
AND WE ARE PROUD TO BE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE THIRTY TWO.
NEXT WE GO TO LINE OF A MARK
THE ALBUM PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU HELLO MY NAME IS MARK
GALA I AM FROM THE CITY TO
STUDENTS OF UC RIVERSIDE I'M
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT I SEE I'M
HERE TO STRONG TO BY STRONG
SUPPORT AT TWELVE THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU. I NEXT WE GO TO LINE
ONE TWENTY THREE ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AB
SAMPLE ON BEHALF OF THE ACT
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIANS SUPPORTED
THAT MEASURE. IT WAS OF ANOTHER
THREE IN THE QUEUE- NEXT WE'LL
GO TO NUMBER ONE TEN ONE TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A NUMBER ONE
TEN PLEASE MAKE SURE NOT ON
MUTE. I WILL GO TO THE LINE
NUMBER ONE TWENTY FOUR ONE
TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CALL CALIFORNIA WHO POLICY
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT. THEN WE
HAVE ONE FINAL IN SUPPORT OF
LASTLY WE GO TO NUMBER NINETY
ONE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME'S TOM PARLOUS
YESTERDAY. AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. HOW WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE COMMON IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
NUMBER ONE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
READING CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS VINCENT
ROSTER LIMóN UNDERGRADUATE
STUDENT THE UC RIVERSIDE AND
REPRESENTATIVE WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SP TWELVE. THANK YOU.
AND AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE. YOUR
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE CHECK
PLAN ONCE AGAIN TO BE SURE WE
HAVE HEARD FROM ALL OF THE-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE THIRTY TWO
ON THE LINE. THOSE SILLY ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN ONE
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT. DO
WE HAVE IT THERE ARE NO FURTHER
IN THE QUEUE THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AT THIS MOMENT WE
WILL. A MAKE SURE TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CORPS WISHING TO TEST TO
COMMENT ON IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO IN ROOM FORTY
TWO ZERO THREE. SEEING NONE. WE
WILL AT THIS POINT A MOVE ON TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TWELVE THIRTY TWO- WE WILL
BEGIN WITH A ROOM FORTY TWO.
ZERO THREE HAVE ANY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. FORTY TWO ZERO
THREE WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. IN OPPOSITION
TO SB TWELVE THIRTY TWO. SEE
NINE. DO WE HAVE- ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO ON THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SERVICE
LINE. MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PUMP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO WE WILL BEGIN.
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MODERATE
CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE ME THE
TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. YES
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE ONE THAT
IS IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES I CALLED THE OPPOSITION-
INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL CONTINUE.
YES WE'LL GO TO A LINE- ONE
THIRTY FOUR ONE THIRTY FOUR YOU
ARE OPEN. HI THIS IS JESSICA
BARCELO CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
YEAH BEGIN YOUR- GREAT I WAS
GONNA FIND A NUMBER THAT I KNOW
OF SO- THIS IS JUST ABOUT ONE
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE AND THE PREVIOUS
MANAGER AS WELL I HAD TO HANG
UP O THE PRIMARY PHONE CALL
BECAUSE I WASN'T BEING CALLED
ON AND I APOLOGIZE FOR CALLING
AND I AM NOT IN OPPOSITION I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE AND
YOU HAVE RECEIVED MY LETTER. I
THANK THEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AB THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE ME A TOTAL NUMBER
OF PEOPLE AND TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. ONE CHAMPION
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NONE
IN THE QUEUE. THANK YOU AT THIS
POINT TO A SCENE THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMITTEE
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. SO AT
THIS POINT SENATOR GLAZERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. WELL THANK YOU CAN IT
FOR HEARING THE BILL EIGHT. HI
THIS IS A MODEST BUT IMPORTANT
HELP FOR STUDENTS PARENTS YOU
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT OUT I
ABLE LIAR EDUCATION DEGREE CAN
BE. SUCH AS GETTING THEM INTO
THE SYSTEM AND GET THROUGH. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WILL HELP
WITH APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION TODAY AND CREATE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZER OUT WE HAVE
A MOTION- TO MOVE THE BILL BY
SENATOR- WIENER. US SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB ONE TWO THREE TWO BY GLAZER-
THE MOTION IS DID PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS HER TACO. I
FOLLOW I JONES I JONES FIVE
BELL. TELL BY JACKSON ALL RIGHT
JACKSON I MELENDEZ. PAN BY HAND
AYE WIENER AYE WIENER BY. SIX
ONE NINE FOUR SIX ZERO. THE
VOTE IS SIX ZERO IN THE BILL IS
OUT. AND I AT THIS POINT I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND HANDED OVER
TO OUR VICE CHAIR SENATOR JONES
FOR THE NEXT BILL. GREAT THANK
YOU THINK CENTER TITLED-
PRESENTING SB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. AND CENTER TOTAL YOU NOW
HAVE THE FLOOR BACK. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT SB THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE WHICH WILL ALLOW CAL WORKS
FAMILIES WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE
BEEN PLACED IN FOSTER CARE
CONTINUE RECEIVING MONTHLY CASH
ASSISTANCE WELL THE
REUNIFICATION EFFORTS ONGOING
WITHIN THE TILED WELFARE
SYSTEM. THE CURRENT PRACTICE
REMOVING CASH ASSISTANCE FROM A
FAMILY THAT IS ALREADY BELOW
THE POVERTY LINE MAKES IT EVEN
MORE DIFFICULT. YOU KNOW I WITH
THEIR CHILDREN. ADDITIONALLY A
COULD DESTABILIZE THE FAMILY
AND ULTIMATELY RESOLVED THE
FAMILY BECOMING HOMELESS. GIVEN
THE SIGNIFICANT HOUSING CRISIS
FAMILIES ACROSS THE STATE ARE
FREE SEEN IT IS TIME TO READ.
TO RE VISIT THE POLICY DECISION
THAT ALLOW SERVICES BUT NOT
CASH ASSISTANCE TO CONTINUE
DURING REUNIFICATION EFFORTS.
DESTABILIZING FAMILY TO THE
POINT OF FOOLISHNESS IS
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO OTHER
EFFORTS TO SUPPORT FAMILIES
WELL THE SEEK TO REUNIFY WITH
THE CHILDREN. IMPORTANTLY THIS
BILL ALL PLACE TO FAMILIES THAT
ARE ACTIVELY WORKING ON
REUNIFICATION WITH CHILD
WELFARE WORKERS MEANING THAT
THE CHILD HAS BEEN REMOVED.
FROM THE PARENT AND PLACED IN
OUT OF HOME CARE WHICH IS
DEFINED AS TEMPORARY CARE
SITUATION AND ONE THE RECORDS
THE REUNIFICATION CLASS. THIS
DOES NOT BODE CASES WHERE THE
CHILD WAS REMOVED BUT THE
COUNTY DOES. NOT RECOMMEND
FAMILY REUNIFICATION SERVICES.
SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE WILL
ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF CHILD
WELFARE PROGRAMS TO REUNIFY
FOSTER CHILDREN WITH THEIR
PARENTS BY ALLOWING CAL WORKS
FAMILIES WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE
BEEN PLACED IN FOSTER CARE. TO
CONTINUE RECEIVING MONTHLY CASH
ASSISTANCE. ALL ACTIVE
REUNIFICATION EFFORTS ARE OP
WHEN IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM. AND WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE A SPONSOR OF THE BILL SB
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE JOINING US
REMOTELY. MODERATOR THERE'S A-
WITNESS ON THE LINE IF YOU CAN
CALL IT THAT WITNESS PLEASE. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN YES. OKAY GREAT KATHY
SUNDERLAND MCDONNELL AS A
COUNTY ONE OF WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OR PLEASE BONTA
THIS LEGISLATION WE ALSO
SPONSORED THE BILL ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS AGO THAT ALLOWED FOR
SERVICES TO BE PROVIDED TO
THESE PARENTS WHILE THE
CHILDREN WERE IN ACTIVITY
REUNIFICATION EFFORT. AT THAT
TIME THE- THEY NOT TO ALLOW THE
GRANTS TO CONTINUE IN THE
INTERVENING TWENTY YEARS WE
REALLY HAVE SUCCESS WITH THE
POSITION OF THE SERVICES THAT
IS HELP TO BETTER COORDINATE.
OUR COUNTY DEPARTMENT AND HER
CHILD ARMAND SO FAMILIES ARE
TRYING TO JUGGLE THE REQUIRE
BOTH SYSTEMS AND NOT DOING VERY
WELL AT EITHER WHICH IS WHAT WE
NEED TO HISTORICALLY THEME
HAPPENED. WELL NAT WHAT IS THAT
OR AN IN WITH THE SIGNET HOUSES.
THE VERY HIGH COST OF LIVING
AND- EVEN MORE RECENTLY
OBVIOUSLY THE ECONOMIC
SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC IT MAKES EVEN MORE
SENSE TO REVISIT THE QUESTION
OF CONTINUING THE GRANT FOR THE
FAMILY. WE'VE MADE SOME EFFORT
TO HELP STABILIZE FAMILIES WHEN
THEIR CHILDREN ARE REMOVED FROM
THEIR- SUCH AS THE BREACH. HOME
PRO. WILL PROVIDE HOUSING
SUPPORT FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE%
HOMELESS ARE ON THE VERGE OF
BECOMING HOMELESS. THEY CAN GET
THEIR KIDS BACK IF THEY'RE
HOMELESS WE DON'T TAKE A CHILD
OUT OF THE HOME JUST BECAUSE
THEY'RE HOW MUCH. A JUDGE WILL
NOT RETURN TO TALK TO A CAR OR
ANOTHER COMPLETELY AND HOUSING
SITUATION AT THE WE'VE BEEN
DOING A LOT OF WORK TO TRY TO
HELP STABILIZE THE FAMILY. AND
TO OUR MEMBERS. WATER RIVAS
QUESTION. WE HOPE TO HELP THAT
AVOID GETTING STABLE IN THE
FIRST PLACE BY GOING AHEAD A
CONTINUING THE MODEST GRANT TO
THAT FAMILY WHILE THEY ACTIVELY
WORK WITH OUR CHILD WELFARE
STAFF TO REUNIFY WITH THEIR
CHILD WE COULD GO GIVE MORE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES A BETTER
SHOT AT GETTING UNIFIED AND
ALSO HELP TO KEEP FAMILY STABLE
ESPECIALLY AT THIS TIME
PARTICULARLY. CRISIS YOU I'M
SURE I VOTE AND I KNOW TO IN
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LET'S GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
RIGHT NOW DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. THEIR WISHES SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
SAYING NOW AND WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
ARE WE GOING TO TWENTY FORTY
TODAY NO OKAY SO NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY. I WILL GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE OR IS MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY-
WITNESSES OR- SPEAKERS WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE. ON THE TELEPHONE
LINE. OF THE GERMAN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN A ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT.
RESTAURANT WHERE DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YES AT
THIS TIME WE HAVE TWO THAT ARE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. SO YOU GO
TO NUMBER ONE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE SAM SAYS
ON THE HEALH OF THE FBI YOU
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORTER.
AND THEN WE GO TO LINE OF JUST
GO BARCELO PLEASE GOOD. HI
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS
JESSICA BACK WELL WHEN THE
WESTERN CENTER ON POVERTY AND
SUPPORTERS MEASURE AND IF I MAY
JUST ADD THAT WE HAVE SEEN
CLIENTS IN THE SITUATION. AND
THEY ARE ALSO WHEN OUR CHILDREN
ARE REMOVED THERE ARE SO
INELIGIBLE FOR GENERAL
ASSISTANCE AND SO OFTEN TIMES
THEY COME HOME THAT'S RIGHT
AWAY. AND IS VERY DESTABILIZING
BOTH FOR THEM AND THEIR
CHILDREN AND VERY DIFFICULT TO
GET THEM IN A PLACE WHERE THEY
CAN RECEIVE THE CHILDREN BACK
EVEN WITH THE JUDGE'S ORDERS SO
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
CAPTION THIS. LIST. AUTHOR
HERSELF AS WELL. AND WE ARE DRY
UP THANK YOU. THANK THE SMART
CAN YOU ASK ONE MORE TIME IF
THERE'S ANY- SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN FORTY ONE.
ONE CAN IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN THE
QUEUE. THANK YOU LET'S GO TO
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN FORTY
TWO OR THREE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN FORTY
ONE. SAYING NINE OVER THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY-
SPEAKERS IN THE QUEUE FOR. IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE. BUT YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. IN ONE ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION. ARE THERE ANY
SPEAKERS AT IN NONE IN THE
QUEUE. I THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR WILL BRING THE CAN
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
DíAS- FOR MEMBER COMMENTS.
WELL BILLS MOOD BY SENATOR
WINNER ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
CENTER TOTAL YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THAT'S CALDERON.
SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE HER TADO
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS FURTADO I
AM RICARDO I JONES HI JONES
AIBO. WELL I JACKSON ALL RIGHT
JACKSON BY MELINDA'S. PAN HI AN
ONLINE WIENER WIENER AYE. SIX
ZERO. THAT DOES NOT BILL IS OUT
ON A VOTE OF SIX TO ZERO. WERE
WRAPPED UP IN ALL TURN THE
GAVEL BACK TO THE CHAIR WOMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE. COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION.
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION- WE
HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE
SENATE. COMMITTEE ON HUMAN
SERVICES IS ADJOURNED.